well I'm now in the port city of Aiden
and let's remember that children are by
far the biggest victims in this war
according to the latest United Nations
figures one child in Yemen dies every 10
minutes from preventable causes that's
completely unnecessary deaths and there
are a staggering 11 million children in
Yemen who are in need of humanitarian
Aid and assistance who basically go
hungry every day well there's no one who
knows more about how acute the situation
is than the UNICEF representative in the
country Peter Hawkins and he joins us
now Peter Hawkins you've seen the
desperation in just the first report
that we've done we have further reports
later on today which show very
controversially how shopkeepers in
hodeidah area in the province of
hodeidah are selling United Nations food
Aid apparent currently because people
need to sell the aid that they've been
given free to get medicine How concerned
are you about that how shocked are you
about those Revelations and what can be
done about this
I think the whole situation in Yemen and
it has been the case for eight years now
is is shocking and the figures that
you've Illustrated there about you know
11 000 children have died in the
conflict 11 million children are
desperate in in need and the United
Nations and UNICEF amongst them are
doing everything it can to ensure that
Aid gets to directly to the people
themselves to the women girls and boys
whether it's through education whether
it's through Primary Health Care or
whether it's uh directly as you point
out through food Aid or social
protection we provide 1.5 million
families with uh amounts of money every
three months which equates to about 10
15 of their total needs but you know the
the conflict the economic collapse the
social collapse that has taken place in
Yemen comes with its consequences and
and it's with those consequences that
we're faced with now and which which
you're trying to address on an ongoing
basis
Peter tell us though are you really
saying that you're doing enough I mean
even if you mentioned 15 of their total
budget clearly our evidence on on the
ground is that is just a drop in the
ocean of their desperate needs with
almost everyone we speaking to telling
us how hungry they are and quite visibly
being on the point in some cases of
dying do you really feel you're doing
enough and what can you do to make other
countries other areas of the world step
up and and do their bit
we can never do enough and and we're
trying every day to do more and more and
more
um and you know access is is not easy
um the issue around resources it makes
it very difficult and as you can see in
ties the the terrain is is uh incredibly
difficult to try and overcome but I
think Alex as you would see for yourself
there is an opportunity now to do more
to actually start to help build up the
resilience of that population to help
the children uh you know with food more
targeted food more targeted
nutritional intake to be able to build
up their resilience so if the situation
should deteriorate God forbid that they
they can fend for themselves but I think
more importantly if the no war no peace
which is the current situation should
continue let's use that opportunity to
build the services to build the
resilience of the population and ensure
those services are able to deliver
effectively to that population that's
the only sustainable and cost effective
way going forward and it will reach for
majority of the population
mentioned how difficult
are incredibly difficult to get inside
the country because of not only the
armed checkpoints multiple armed
checkpoints across across the country
but just being denied access in the
first place give us an illustration of
how difficult it is for you to operate
on the ground as well
it's much easier for me I mean I live in
in San and I travel all over the country
as indeed to members of my team and we
have uh offices throughout the the
country north south eastern and and West
and we're able to to to move as we uh
require the the issue is trying to move
the materials in into place whether it's
uh ready to to eat food for for
nutrition whether it's to get the
vaccine or the medicines up into some of
these air more remote areas and
effectively delivered to that population
that's that's the the difficulty access
since the the truce which was uh in
April last year has been much much
easier you're correct it takes a lot of
time you're going up sheer mountains the
whole time
um and it's it's much more difficult but
we are beginning to have an impact on
that population and with what we have to
do now over the next few months is
capitalize on the fact that there is no
open conflict and hope that the the
services that we are delivering are
sustained for the medium and longer term
and have a real impact on the the
population
for Aid budgets are being slashed and
the people on the ground are definitely
feeling the impact of those cuts around
the world saying that it's been halved
in just a few months not specifically
mentioning you you and yourself or or
anyone from the United Nations but just
talking about on the ground how they're
getting so much less I wonder how you
encourage anyone the world to now focus
on this war which has got the closest in
eight years to any potential possible
peace deal
at at the end of uh February as you know
Alex the International Community pledged
1.2 billion dollars
um that is on top of probably another
500 to 600 million dollars which has
already been uh committed
um so that's nearly two billion dollars
that uh is about 25 30 of the total
needs but at the beginning of the year
that is a significant pledge uh to take
forward and what we really have to focus
on now is using those resources in the
most effective uh way to ensure that the
population do get sustainable Services
as quickly as possible and the key there
Alex is is really the the system the
health system region reinvigorating the
health system to make sure that it
delivers vaccine in an impeded way it
delivers medicines it ensures that
pregnant women do have access to
antenatal care
um and other services that children do
access schools in one way or another so
that they can learn and and Aspire
towards a better future and we have that
opportunity now uh to be able to do that
so any investment going forward can will
deliver a a return on that investment as
long as there is peace as you've said
Peter Hawkins the UNICEF representative
in Yemen thank you for really valid
points and also illustrating just what a
huge challenge there is ahead even if
peace is declared well you can watch our
exclusive string of reports from inside
Yemen the Forgotten war from 7 30 UK
time tonight